or we have breaking news from this our
summoner redstone's National Amusements
has removed a Viacom CEO philippe de mon
from the Viacom board five other
directors were also removed
Bloomberg's a new Chester Kui is in Los
Angeles also with us as bloomberg anchor
Betty Lou who's been tracking this story
as well Anusha over to you first give us
the latest development five directors
were just single early-out stood from
the board yes so literally just a few
minutes ago we got an announcement that
National Amusements which is the holding
company through which Sumner Redstone
controls Viacom and CBS put out a press
release saying that they were going to
remove five directors including Philip
demolish CEO directors of Viacom they
also include George Abrams by the
McGarvey Frederick Salerno and William
Schwartz
they also named five replacements which
include Kenneth Lera Thomas Mae Judith
McHale Ronald Nelson and Nicole Seligman
it's unclear who would be in the
leadership position amongst those
changes as you might know following this
story it has been twists and turns with
legal fights from California to
Massachusetts as part of this
announcement National Amusements says
it's also seeking that court approval
and this means no show do you know what
prompted this and this is just curtains
for a dome on here supposedly it's been
combed furthermore for a little while
ever since Sumner Redstone started to
make clear through his lawyers that he
was not supporting move by patter by
Viacom to sell estate in its film
company Paramount Pictures that became
even more explicitly obvious yesterday
from a statement by his lawyer from
suddenly redstone which he said he did
not support the CEO you know the
directors have been appealing via public
statements to get access to Sumner who
you know is elderly and there have been
court battles about whether he is you
know in a state to be making decisions
about the company initial what do we
know about Shari redstone Sumner
Redstone daughter who at one point he
was estranged from but now
since dad made amends with yes exactly
so you know one of the accusations is
that you know Shari redstone his
daughter is behind these moves and you
know it has been it has become clear
they have patched up a falling-out that
they had some years ago what's going to
be interesting is that in a matter of a
couple of weeks both Shari redstone and
Philippe d'amour I invited to the Sun
Valley Conference which is hosted by
Allen & Co in Sun Valley Idaho and where
you know the titans of tech tech and
entertainment gather so it's going to be
very interesting to see if either of
those two turn up and face off in public
a new shed that anybody there
if either turn up or both that will be
quite an awkward bird moment they're
gonna have to may be amazing for me
because I'll I'll be there trying to
catch glimpses so for me will be great
entertainment and it would be amazing
because you know this is a very
secretive conference as you know where
the old making often happens and you
know big names get together in
supposedly relaxed environment so it
would be very interesting but I don't
think they would have probably kind
words for each other